today we're going to prove that this
pair of numbers that we're having a look
at here
uh are both irrational now before we
have a go at this proof i think it's
really important that you understand
the frame of mind that you get into
before you actually begin
a proof this question or this pair of
questions comes
in an exercise that's all about proof by
contradiction so that's the technique
that we're going to use in a minute
however
this nothing in the question itself
actually tells you that a proof by
contradiction
is the way to go and one of the primary
skills that mathematicians
need to develop and employ all the time
is that they
sort of develop like a toolbox all these
different strategies and techniques and
approaches
and one of the most important skills
they have is to choose between
all of the different approaches based on
which one is most efficient or which one
is most elegant
or appropriate to the task now in some
topics that's very very obvious
we were looking at complex numbers
recently and if you get a question
it's about complex numbers and it asks
something to do with angles
then you're probably going to want to
get your complex number out of
rectangular form
and potentially into mod arg form or
even exponential form because
that makes much clearer what angles
you're operating with within the
question
but when you're having a look at the
topic the nature of proof we've seen all
kinds of different
techniques we've looked at uh the direct
proofs we've looked at proof by
contradiction proof by the
contrapositive
how do you know which one is most
appropriate now i'm going to give you
some suggestions by having a read of
this question
as to why you might think even if it
wasn't in an exercise about proof by
contradiction
why there are actually clues in here
that would lead you to think proof by
contradiction is the way to go so let's
have a look at the question
and get started question 13 part a prove
that the square root of 6 is irrational
so
right there is our first major clue in
fact it's kind of the only clue
that you need because we're trying to
prove that in the first instance
this square root of 6 number is
irrational i want you to think about
what the word
irrational means um it literally is
about the fact that you
cannot that's what the ir at the sta at
the start stands for
you cannot express a number as a ratio
or we would more colloquially say as a
fraction
so i mean it's kind of an established
result that serds like this
where the number underneath the square
root sign
is um it's not a square number so of
course you're going to get something
irrational but
how do we actually prove that to be the
case
now it's tricky to go about this
directly and this is me getting at why
you might think
why mathematicians would conclude let's
have a go at doing this by
contradiction to say that a number is
irrational
is to say that that number does not
have some certain qualities about it
it does not have some characteristics in
this case that it can be expressed
as a ratio now it's quite hard to deal
with something
when you're just saying things that it
doesn't do it's it's like
trying to define something and you you
know the things that it's not if i ask
you
or if you ask me what's your favorite
food and i just told you all the foods
that i dislike you're like well i mean
that's all true
but you're not getting me any closer to
working out what meal we should have i'm
just knowing the meals to avoid
so the reason why i prove my
contradiction here is helpful
is because the basic building block in a
proof by contradiction is not the
statement
that you're trying to prove it's the
negation
of that statement if the statement
you're trying to prove is a
you know here's something i can't do or
here's some quality i don't have
then the negation of that would be this
number
does have some quality or some attribute
or some characteristic and if you assume
that you can then you know perhaps write
some equations or
apply some symbols to that and then you
can do some work on it of course because
we're working with the negation we will
eventually lead to something untrue
something absurd
and that's why this is going to be our
goal so let's have a go at this
it is somewhat a classic proof but i
wanted you to know
why we were going about the proof and
not just that you can do it so let's
have a go
at part a to do this by contradiction
as i just alluded to i need to know what
the negation of this statement is and
then we'll assume that
to be true it's a relatively simple
statement that they're giving us here
that root six is
irrational so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to assume
that the opposite is true that root 6 is
rational now what this immediately
allows us to do
is make a statement about the square
root of 6 and then start to apply logic
and like algebraic manipulation to it
and that kind of thing and we're going
to lead to
our contradiction so we're assuming that
the square root of 6
is rational which means that i can say
therefore
the square root of 6 is equal to a ratio
of two
integers so i'm just going to give them
names i'm going to call them p and q
and i do need to say where p and q
are integers because i'm dealing with
the square root of 6 the square root
function in
the real number world is only defined
for positive numbers so therefore i can
i can restrict and say i want these both
to be positive in order for the fraction
to
give me the square root of 6. now this
is a good start but that's not the only
thing that i need to be able to say
if p and q share some factors then
things are going to cancel and i'm not
going to get a ratio
anymore so i actually need to apply an
additional
restriction on p and q not just that
they are positive
integers but that they share no factors
so i'm just going to write that
p and q share no factors so
no canceling can happen on this um i
will also mention
um just while i'm here we do have
because this idea of
numbers not sharing factors like say um
10 and uh what's a good example that i
could give you should have thought of
one off the top of my head it's going to
be an odd number because 10 is
even 10 and say 21
10 and 21 they share no factors we would
say because that idea of sharing no
factors is an important mathematical
concept
we give that its own label we call that
co
prime neither 10 not 21 are prime
numbers they're both composite
but they're co-prime when you consider
them together they don't share
any factors 10 only has 2 and 5.
21 only has 3 and 7. we're not worrying
about one because the trivial case
i really should say share no prime
factors but you get the idea i just want
to avoid cancelling being able to happen
all right now where do i go from here
remember where i'm trying to head is i'm
trying to
work with this thing in order to lead to
a contradiction that's part of what's a
bit weird
we're used to getting equations and you
just solve them like find the pronumeral
isolate it do whatever you need to but
here i'm trying to
lead to something that isn't true so
what can i do with this
first thing i'm going to say is i want
to get as quickly as i can away from
this
square root of 6. it's very hard to work
with right i'm dealing with these
these integers over here and root six
just is not coming to the parties so
what could i do to this equation to
eliminate this
pesky uh serd and a label to
interact with the rest of the numbers
that i have here
and you're probably thinking about it
already square root of 6 to get rid of
the square root part of it
i'm going to square so let's square both
sides that gives me 6
and it gives me p squared on q squared
on
the right hand side now that's slightly
better
and now everything at least is in uh
integer world
um above i've got whole numbers but i'm
still i'm still not quite there yet
i need to get to a contradiction of some
kind and
remember um you know there are all of
these these
things that i said about p and q
potentially if i could get to the point
where p
and q i show that they can't possibly be
whole numbers that would be a
contradiction so that would be great
or p and q if i could show that they
shared factors that would also be a
contradiction
and there's a whole suite of other
things that i could um try and work
toward
so in order to talk about one of these
let's think about this sharing factors
business right
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
multiply both sides by this q
squared term over here right because
that's going to help me
get to a factorization that is is useful
to me so
i'm going to write not just 6
q squared but i'm actually going to
write 2 times 3
q squared so you'll see why in a second
i've taken this
6 and i've just written it as 2 times 3
having multiplied both sides by q
squared that just leaves me with p
squared
on the right hand side now think
carefully with me
what does this imply this tells me
that p squared because it is
2 times some other integer
i know if q is an integer then q squared
will be an integer and
3q squared will also be an integer p
squared is double
some integer well if you're double an
integer what that tells you is that
you're even
i mean that's what even means right so i
can say this line here
this implies that p squared is
even okay so far so good um what can i
do with that though
how can i lead from this to a
contradiction well
this means that i can actually make some
statements about p
what kind of number p is if p squared is
even i actually know something already
about p itself uh maybe the the gears
are turning we've actually done this
proof uh within
earlier exercises and not looking at
proof by contradiction
think about this right i'm actually
going to go about this using another
tool that we've got the um
the contrapositive right what i want to
say is if you have
p being odd uh
think of any odd number you like um
three seven
nine five i don't know why i skipped
five and so on and so on
what you can say is in fact i don't even
need to put that if there
i can say but if p is odd that implies
that p squared is odd
square of 3 is 9 that's odd square of 5
is 25 that's odd and you can prove that
algebraically of course
let's just do that right now if i said
that p was equal to some
2k plus 1 where k was
an integer think about what happens when
you square that right
what that tells you is that p squared is
going to be let's just take the binomial
and expand it
2 k plus 1 or squared will be
4 k squared plus 4 k
plus 1. there's the a squared 2 a b plus
b
squared and you can see here this
component here clearly is even
it's like super even not just multiplied
by 2 you multiply it
by 2 twice and then you add 1
to that so an even number plus 1 it's
odd so
if you start with an odd number then
when you square it you also
have an odd number but that means i can
take this tool the contrapositive i can
say by the contrapositive
what is a contrapositive well you negate
both
parts of an implication and you reverse
the order
if we said that this is p implies q then
what i'm going to say is
not q implies not p that's a bit
confusing because i'm using the
the pronumeral p here but let me write
it and you can see if it makes sense to
you
the negation of this is p squared is
even
by the conjugate positive p squared is
even
that will imply the negation of the
first part you can see i've switched
around
the order of um the antecedent and the
consequent
part of this implication so p is
even as well and if you just think about
some examples of this that's obviously
true
so what i can say is going back to you
know what does this mean
i can say therefore there exists
some value of n that's an integer and
i'm going to restrict it to positive
because p
itself is also positive there exists
some value of n
within the positive integers such that
p equals 2n that's the point of saying
that it's even so what i'm going to do
is i'm going to take this
new way of writing p and substitute it
back into i suppose i should give this a
name let's call
this equation up here let's call it
equation
1 so that i can name it i can say
substitute
that p equals 2n let's substitute that
into
1. okay what do we get so i'm going to
write this as
2 times 3 q squared equals
2 to n rather not 2p i just substituted
part p to n all squared so you can see
here
this is going to become 4n squared over
here right
which if i simplify that out
for n squared you can see there's going
to be some cancelling happen between
this factor this has a factor of 2 and
of course there's a two sitting right
there
so what does that give us 3 q squared
equals
2 n squared but hold up
this now tells us that 3 q squared this
number on the left hand side
just like my earlier argument about why
p squared had to be even
because it was double an integer well
now i can say that 3q squared is also
even because it's double and integer so
this implies this line here implies
that 3q squared is
even now even means that there's a
factor of 2 but
you're not going to get that from the 3
3 itself is prime it's
not going to contribute evenness to my
3q squared
so if 3q squared is even that means q
squared
must be even but as we saw above by
using the contrapositive
q squared being even means that q
is also even so right that implication
q is even so where has this led
us and the answer is we are at a
contradiction
we have p and q both being even i can
say
well therefore p and q
are both even and that implies
or i mean it's even the definition that
p and q share
a factor
of two and this is the contradiction so
you can see
i've landed on a fact that sort of
well it flies in the face of the way we
started this that p and q
are positive integers that share no
factors that are
co-prime well i've just shown you just
take that assumption
and you end up with the fact that in
fact they are not co-prime they share a
factor so
contradiction square root of six can't
possibly
be rational which is what my assumption
was therefore
uh the square root of six is irrational
done okay take a breath
how do we use this because you can see
this is just a part a
of uh two parts how do we use this to do
the next part of the question
hence prove that root three plus root
two
is irrational now obviously i could go
about this i could kind of rehearse this
entire thing for the square root of
three
and for the square root of two and then
say oh look i have two irrational
numbers
does that help us right well there are
actually some sneaky reasons
why that's not uh that's not going to be
useful but also we have been told look
you got to use that logic that you just
proved and this is the best way
to prove that uh or it is a very elegant
way i should say difficult to say best i
don't know every other proof
out there in the universe this is a very
efficient way to prove
that root 3 plus root 2 is rational if i
use this root 6
being irrational so i'm going to do it
in a similar kind of
using a similar structure because
proving something is irrational is
tricky
i'm going to assume that it's rational
and then see
what happens from there so another proof
by contradiction
on the way part b let's assume
that the square root of 3 plus the
square root of 2
let's assume that that whole thing when
you combine it together
it is rational so it belongs to the set
of rational numbers that's the way i can
write that
if that is true you know when you square
a rational number you should get
another rational number out because you
know if you if you have
um you know 5 over 7 there's a rational
number uh when you square that
5 squared on 7 squared well no big deal
uh
the numerators still are a whole number
an integer
denominator is still an integer um so
you're good to go right
so therefore i'm going to consider and
maybe this is where you're thinking oh
this is the connection to part a
i'm going to consider i shouldn't write
it therefore i'm going to
consider what happens when we square
this thing right
wow that's really messy too let's try
that again all right this is just a
classic binomial expansion we've already
done one earlier today but let's
go through it slowly together a plus b
all squared is a squared plus two a b
plus b squared so what's a squared in
this case it's the square root of three
squared so that just gives me three um i
then do the two a b
so that's double square root of three
square root of 2
and then i've got my b squared along the
end which is
2. so now i've got gathering collecting
like terms i've got 3 and the 2 giving
me
5. then i've got a 2 here and by
combining the square root of 3 and the
square root of 2 that product of course
is the square root of 6.
now we see the connection to that whole
reason why we proved square root of 6 is
irrational
i can say but the square root of 6
it belongs to the irrational numbers um
you might remember
um we have this tilde the tilde g does
some heavy lifting um it means a lot of
things it means approximately
if you put underneath it means vectors
in this context it means
you know you're in the complement um you
know we've seen this also with uh
with logic you can use this uh tilde as
a negation
square root of six is in the set of
irrational numbers and therefore
uh oopsie daisy therefore uh this
square here duplicate that
that is it can't possibly uh be
in the set of rational numbers because
it's got this irrational number tucked
away in it
that is going to be a contradiction
right
we can say well if the square isn't a
rational number
then the number you started from can't
possibly be rational
either so i can say this is a
contradiction
and therefore
square root of 3 plus the square root of
2
is irrational so
i hope that's helpful the lessons that i
take out of this are
number one think carefully about why it
is that you would choose
one method of proof versus another think
about what's easiest
or most convenient to you and then
secondly you know when you're thinking
about how to
you know do some of these hence
questions these kinds of things
are are going to lead from this you want
to think about how you can get from
the particular result you need to prove
from this connected result so where does
root 6
appear in square root of 3 and square
root of 2 and it's the product between
them so that's why squaring was the
natural thing
to do